- You know what?
I need everybody to be quiet for a second,
because I want to touch
on a serious subject.
I forget what it was
but they're like, he's not going to stop.
My boy's like, he's
just not going to stop.
He's going to do this until he makes it.
Everyone's creativity
is their own creativity
so if you don't like it,
that doesn't mean that
this person over here
does not going to like it.
It's like, people love vulnerability.
'Cause it's showing that you're human
and it's showing that you're
like, you make mistakes.
- No way!
Oh snap, this guy's a drummer, I like it!
- He's a Canadian singer and songwriter.
He's the first artist to have seven songs
from a debut album chart
on the Billboard Hot 100.
He's sold an estimated 100
million albums worldwide,
making him one of the best
selling artists of all time.
He's Justin Bieber,
and here's my take on his
top 10 rules for success.
Rule number 10 is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
Also, as Justin is talking,
if he says something that's really deep
and meaningful to you,
please leave it in the comments
and put quotes around it
so other people can enjoy as well.
(dramatic music)
- [Zach] Dan's very, he's been studying
your dance moves for a while.
- Oh yeah?
Show me something.
- [Zach] He's been, this is it!
- No, no.
All right, you know,
I'll embarrass myself.
- [Justin] Show me.
- So you know the part
in the Confident video
when you guy's are,
like, walkin' in the hall
and you're doing that little thing.
Every time I see that, I
just can't control myself.
I can't do it.
- Do it.
Just try, try, try.
- [Woman Off Screen] Do it, do it!
- I can show you.
You want me to show you?
- Teach me that.
- So, I think.
So, so you're doing, like, a 360.
- Your whole body?
- No, just with this.
- Okay.
- Your fingers, so you go,
then you throw it this way.
- Oh, so this one goes in the back?
(people laughing)
- So you're just.
- [Woman Off Screen]
This is Dan's journey.
- All right, here we go.
Circle.
So, step with the circle.
- Okay, so, so step, back.
- Step, throw it.
- [Woman Off Screen] Okay.
- [Woman Off Screen]
You guys look like bros.
- I think that was pretty good.
- You are brother.
Let me see it by yourself.
- Okay.
So step, throw it, step, throw it.
Step, throw it.
- [Zach] Well done!
- [Woman Off Screen] Let's
go down, let's go down, good.
- [Dan] No, no ,no.
- [Woman Off Screen] No, no,
no, start over, start over!
- We're telling there's another one.
- You got it, I'm not watching.
You're not, you got to
commit with the circle.
Just focus on your body.
- [Dan] It's all in the hand.
- It's all in the wrist, dude.
- [Dan] So I got to.
No, no, that was bad too.
So, step.
- [Woman Off Screen] Dan, you're choking!
- Dude, it's not.
- He's got it!
Relax.
You're doing great.
- [Dan] Step, bro.
- It's actually circle.
You're missing this.
You're missing.
The full, I guess it's almost.
So when you're stepping,
you're throwing it like
that, so boom, two spins.
- Listen, I'll just
stick with the slow one,
and then I'll leave you to the fast,
I'll be one, I'll just,
I'll just go real slow,
and you go real fast.
- All right.
- So it's all.
(people laughing)
I got it, I got it like once!
- It's a dumb move anyway.
(people laughing)
It's on the move right?
- Because that's the greatest
move I ever see.
- Blame it on the move.
The move sucks.
- Terrible dance move,
I don't know why you would
ever put that in a video,
that sucks.
- [Woman Off Screen] Dan's also part
of the skate life, though, so.
- Yeah?
- He skates, too.
- Well, I try.
- Let's skate.
Let's go skating after this.
- [Zach] There are
skateboards in the other room!
- Oh, they're in my car
now, but yeah, they're here.
- [Zach] You ready for this?
She rollerblades and he skateboards.
- Well, we both try, I
mean, we're not great
but it's fun, right?
- Bros.
- That's what I say.
This is my dog, right here.
- I know.
- I'm going to move over to his mic.
- [Zach] Go, move up.
Share with him.
- This is my new best friend.
For sure, yeah, there's
times where I'm just like,
man, this is a lot, I
just want to go home.
I'm just, like, exhausted, I'm tired.
But I just also remember
what I want in life
and what I'm driving, like, striving for
and I'm striving for the most,
just the best career possible
and to have the most people
be able to listen to my music
and be touched by my music
so you got to do the other stuff
that not necessarily what you love
but it goes along with everything else.
- [Interviewer] What
is your biggest regret?
- My biggest regret is probably.
I think everything that I
did made me who I am today
and I have a story, and I just carry,
there's a story in the Bible
which talks about this dude
who Jesus healed and he said,
pick up your mat and go.
And so what that symbolizes,
like, pick up your past,
he was a paraplegic and he's like,
pick up this mat so you
remember where you were.
So for me, I just remember where I was
and I'm not where I want to be necessarily
but I'm not where I used to
be and just keep it pushing.
- You're a drummer.
- Yeah.
- I'm a drummer.
- Really?
- I am a drummer.
- That's awesome.
- You know what a paradiddle
is and everything, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Just do a paradiddle right now, right.
No way!
Oh snap, this guy's a drummer, I like it!
Okay, it wasn't just
like a privilege he's a,
your gig, sometimes you
just tell the drummer,
you go, take five, man, I got this
and you start playing it off.
- I've been playing since I was two.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- Yup.
- So you're like a jack of all trades.
I mean, you play guitar, you sing,
you got rhythm, you play drums.
What about doing, like, a solo album
where you do everything on it?
That ever crossed your mind?
- That could be cool.
I just, like.
I'm so, like, there's
so many amazing drummers
and so many amazing guitar
players, like, I'm not there yet.
Like, I love playing
guitar, I love drumming
but I'm not going to say
that I'm excellent at it.
Like I'm good, like, I'm really good.
- It's something you love to do, right?
- Yeah, they're, they're great but like,
there's people who all they do is drum,
all they do is play guitar.
So I want those type of
people on my album, you know?
- Absolutely.
- It's like, people love vulnerability.
'Cause you're showing that you're human
and you're showing that you're like,
you make mistakes and
you are human and you.
It's just relatable.
- There's strength in
vulnerability, though, right?
- [Justin] Yeah.
- There's strength in you coming out
and explaining how vulnerable you are.
- [Justin] Yeah, for sure.
- And how open you are.
- For sure.
And it takes a lot as a man too
to be able to suck that pride up and not,
and, because for a while I just, like,
you don't want to say sorry,
you don't want to feel
like you're weak, you know
'cause a lot of the times
when you show your emotions,
you feel weak or people
tell you that that's weak
when you cry or when you do this.
I'm like, I'm a really emotional guy,
so I'm like, I'm a crier.
I'm someone who's like, really
open with my emotions
and for a while I felt like I couldn't be
and I felt so guarded
that I wasn't being
able to be my true self.
And like, that rock star
lifestyle that's just like,
it was cool and it was
fun but it just wasn't me.
♫ This life's not easy
♫ I'm not made out of steel
♫ Forget that I'm human
♫ Forget that I'm real
♫ You act like you know me
♫ But you never will
(crowd cheering)
Thank you, thank you.
We're all in this together.
Why am I crying so hard?
God, get it together, Justin.
We're in this together, you know?
Thank you, thank you.
I got to go, thank you.
(crowd cheering loudly)
- There's one time, you're on stage
and you're trying to kick
like a jujube or something into the crowd.
Well, maybe you were on
the side of the stage
throwing it at 'em.
- What in the world
are you talking about?
- No, no, no, because he just--
- Yeah, we just were doing crazy stuff.
Like, we used to have these,
like, sound check parties,
is that you're talking about?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, yeah, that's exactly
what it was, yeah.
- And before we do,
like, weird games, and
he'd throw something
to me and I'd try to kick it
and I wouldn't stop until I got it.
I'm like that type of dude.
Like, the other day, I forget what it was
but they were like,
he's not going to stop.
My boy's like, he's
just not going to stop,
he's going to do this until he makes it.
- I saw it that day, so
is it that competitiveness
to where, like, when
everybody's comin' down on you,
you feel like the media
isn't being fair to you,
at some point, you got competitive
and just started fighting back, right?
- Well, the thing is is
that throughout it all,
I always knew my talent level
and I knew what I was capable of
so I was never worried about coming back.
You know, that might sound weird
and 'cause it was, I was
such in a weird place
but I always knew what I was capable of
and at that time I was just growing up
and figuring myself out
and I just happened to be
doing it in a spotlight
in front of people so it
was a little different.
You guys got to make your mistakes
and no one got to see
it, you know, and for me,
it's like everyone gets to see it
and obviously I have more
accessibility to do crazier stuff
'cause I'm in this position but yeah.
Dude, I just had to figure out
what kind of man I wanted to be and.
- And I thought, man, he's so lucky.
Nothing happened, man.
Have you got any tips for
me to try and get my luck.
- I don't know if it's luck though, dude.
(laughing)
- Just put me to bed.
- Of course, I'm making pop
music so it has to be popular
but what is popular, necessarily?
Popular is popular when
you make it popular.
You know what I mean, it's not
taking what's already popular
and just, oh, this is popular,
I guess this is popular too.
- [Zach] There's no
stereotype for popular.
- No and I think when, like,
I just want to break those barriers,
we're already breaking the barriers
with having EDM and pop mixed
and playing on Top 40 radio,
you know what I mean?
So if we continue to just
break those barriers,
I think there's only going up from here.
- So you just finished an album, right,
just a few days ago in Aussie?
- Yep.
- How hard is it to actually
just finish an album
and be like, it's done, no
more touch ups, no more edits.
- It is, it's just,
'cause it never feels
like it's done, right?
It just never feels like
it's quite good enough
and you just have to get it to a point
where you're just like, fine with it.
And so I'm at the point
where I'm just like,
it's as good as it's
going to get for right now
and I just want the world to hear it.
- Who do you show it to?
Like, do you show it
to your mom, you know,
do you get a few friends around?
- I show it to all the people in my circle
and all the people who I respect
and care what they think.
But at the end of the day,
I don't really take what they say
and it doesn't really matter to me
because everyone's creativity
is their own creativity
so if you don't like it,
that doesn't mean that
this person over here
is not going to like it.
It's just a personal preference.
- How do you, Justin
Bieber, measure success?
Do you measure it, like, what
is, like, winning to you?
- I mean, creating something that you love
or doing something that you love
and being passionate about it
and like, it's not like I
have to get a number one
to succeed with this song.
I succeeded when I recorded it.
'Cause I was able to do what I loved
and put it on pen and paper, and yeah.
- And when you're making those songs
and writing those songs
and recording them,
do you ever think about,
oh, I wonder if the public'll like this
or I wonder if fans will like it.
- Yep, all the time.
- [Host] Do you?
- All the time, yeah.
You never know what people
are going to to like
and I've just got the
point where just accepting
what I feel and just going with my gut.
- Now, all this happened
because you were discovered
in 2007 on your own YouTube channel.
- Yeah, on my own YouTube in Canada, yeah.
- So if kids want to set
up a YouTube channel,
do you have any tips for them?
- I would just say, learn
how to tag the video right
because that really like,
just put like, cute kittens
'cause a lot of people
search cute kittens.
- Would you say that's the
number one, cute kittens?
- Yeah, just tag yourself as
even if you don't have any
cute kittens in the video,
just say cute kittens and I'm
sure you'll get some likes.
- Okay, and then so, this
guy sees one of your videos,
and is he still your manager?
- Scooter's still my manager, yep.
- And how does it work, your
relationship with Scooter?
Does he do everything you say,
do you do everything he says?
Have you had a row?
Did you split up?
Have you get back together?
Are your songs about him?
- My songs are about him, no.
He's someone who's probably
one of the most talented
businessmen that I've ever met
but he's also someone who really cares.
You know, it's not all
about the money for him,
it's about being passionate
about what he loves,
and he got a great family
and someone who will just,
yeah, he's awesome.
- All right, so we're going to play.
Here's your paddle.
I'm sure you have one, but this is--
- Can we spank each other with these?
- Yes, you can, you can
do whatever you want.
I'm going to have a question and
we're going to answer honestly.
I've never seen these, so, okay.
Never have I ever had phone sex.
(audience laughing)
- You liar!
- I'm not lying.
- Really?
Wow.
- Wow, never have I ever used
someone else's toothbrush
without telling them.
Ew.
(audience laughing)
Never have I ever fooled around
in a bathroom during a party.
(audience laughing)
- This is the 21st century.
- These are tame.
- Yeah, let's--
- Never have I ever gotten
kicked out of a bar.
- I just turned 21.
- [Ellen] Be honest.
- [Ellen] Turn that thing around, Justin.
- I just turned 21.
- J?
- I swear.
- All right.
Never have I ever dated
someone and their sibling.
(audience laughing and cheering)
Never have I ever fooled around
with someone else in the room.
When someone else in the room,
- Wave your hands in the air.
I mean, all these questions are sexual.
Just saying.
- Never have I ever forgotten the name
of the person I was fooling around with.
(audience laughing)
Come on!
You two are perfect for each other.
That's all that we have.
- Oh, that's, I want some more.
- I know, it's a fun game, right?
- It is.
- I know.
- I feel like I'm getting
to know my new boyfriend.
(audience cheering)
- Wait, come up with a question
and we'll answer it right now on the spot.
- Never have I ever had.
(audience laughing)
Sex with two different people,
with more than two
different people in one day.
(audience cheering)
- I mean, two different
people in a day, Madonna?
- Here's the thing.
I want it to be special for my wife.
- Aw!
- Aw, I don't buy that.
- You want to play D?
- [Woman] How do you play D?
- You just play defense,
you just try to stop me goin' by you.
- Okay.
- So you go on this side.
- All right.
- And you're just going
to try to steal the ball.
- Okay.
- Ready?
- Yeah.
- All right, now I'll play D.
- Okay.
- Go, go, go, shoot it!
Oh!
She did it, the champ is here!
The champ is here.
- Should we listen to some music?
- Let's do it.
- Do you want to listen to some music?
("Baby" by Justin Bieber)
♫ Oh whoa
- This is such a huge tune.
Okay, ready?
- Ready?
- I'm pumped.
♫ You know you love me
♫ I know you care
♫ Just shout whenever
♫ And I'll be there
♫ You want my love
You want what?
♫ You want my heart
♫ And we will never ever ever be apart
♫ Are we an item
♫ Girl quit playing
♫ We're just friends, what are you saying
♫ Said there's another
look right in my eyes
♫ My first love broke my
heart for the first time
♫ And I was like baby, baby, baby, oh
♫ Like baby, baby, baby, oh
I love you!
♫ I thought you'd always be mine, mine
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Rodrigo Niz asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
what did Justin say that
really had an impact on you?
What words of wisdom kind
of left a mark on you?
Leave it down in the comments,
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I want to give a quick shout out
to Kelly Quittenton,
I hope I pronounced that okay.
Kelly bought 10 copies of my book.
Thank you so much, Kelly.
It really, really,
really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(crowds cheering)
♫ See I never thought that
I could walk through fire
- [Narrator] Justin Bieber is
the world's hottest pop star.
But during his current
smash hit tour of Australia,
there's only been one
person he's wanted to meet.
- What's up, man?
How are you?
Good to see you.
We're going to do a handshake this time.
Last time it was a pound.
Yeah, there we go.
- [Narrator] Casey Heynes,
the Aussie schoolboy
who stood up to a bully
and became a worldwide internet sensation.
- I saw the video, it was pretty cool.
- Yes, I am excited.
(soft piano music)
- [Narrator] The superstar has flown Casey
and his family to Melbourne's
Rod Laver Arena as VIP guests.
Not only are they meeting Justin
and seeing his spectacular show,
but he also has a surprise in store
that will be the envy of millions
of fans around the world.
- You know, I want to bring him out here
because I think he can.
(crowd cheering)
(children arguing)
- [Narrator] This story
began in a schoolyard
in Western Sydney back in March.
A bully and his mates corner
Casey and video their victim
as he cops punch after punch,
until suddenly, he snaps.
- I was just looking at him.
I wasn't really thinking.
I was just, like, yay, finally, it's over.
- I want to ask you,
what was it like, just, like,
was your adrenaline just
rushing when it all happened?
- Yeah.
(chuckles)
- That's it?
- Yeah.
- It was just, it was just.
- Yeah, it just happened.
- So he was just hitting you
and then you just snapped?
- Yeah.
- Has he bullied you before that?
- Yeah, about two weeks prior before that
and that's pretty much it.
- And so then you just retaliated?
- Yeah.
- Just gave him a power bomb?
- [Narrator] The video was
posted online and went viral,
touching the hearts of
everyone who saw it.
The moment that a victim
of bullying finally said,
enough is enough.
- When I saw this story, it
just kind of touched my heart.
- [Steve] All right, little
kid, little kid punching him
and then so the big kid
had too much, and boom!
- He was defe--
They weren't fighting,
he defended himself.
If that was my son, I'd
go, you do it again.
- Everybody on this planet
who has seen your video
is in your corner.
Casey, you're a man, okay?
And I salute you.
- Why do you think that so many people
have reacted the way that
they have to what you did?
- Because people get bullied all the time.
- [Narrator] Everybody wanted to know more
about the boy in the video.
He told his story to ACA.
How long has this been going on?
- In primary school, year two,
all the way up to year six
and once I hit high school,
one person started it, I
had about eight friends.
My eight friends ditched
me that first year
and then the teasing started from there.
- When you say teasing, what do you mean?
- Like, calling me, like,
fatty and all of that
and slapping me across
the back of the head,
like, tripping me,
throwing water bombs at me.
- How often would this stuff go on?
- Practically every day.
- Would you recommend to other people
who are being bullied to do what you did?
- Not really.
- What should they do?
- Try to walk away as much as you can
but if a fight does break out, it happens.
- [Narrator] Casey told a tragic tale
of being bullied all his life.
Our story was seen by millions of people.
One of them was Justin Bieber.
Justin, what did you think
when you saw the video
for the first time?
- I thought, well, when I first saw it,
I saw it on TMZ and I was like,
this is crazy.
I can't believe this, this is amazing.
It shows everybody else
that you have to stand up for yourself
and you can't just take it.
The first thing you do
is either go tell someone
or you can't always hit back
but sometimes you have to
and so I think that was important for you,
especially in that situation
so I'm proud of you.
- Thanks for that.
- [Justin] And so many other
people are proud of you.
- [Woman] We all are.
- [Narrator] But no one is
prouder than Casey's dad Colin.
Justin Bieber was keen to meet him, too.
- How you doing, mate?
- How are you?
- Good.
- So how did you feel
when you saw your son on.
- I was very proud of him.
- [Justin] You were proud of him?
- Very proud of him, yeah.
- Yeah, it must've been heart, you know,
heart aching to see, you
know, people blowing this up.
- Oh yeah, well, you see
kids getting pushed around
like that in the schoolyard,
it should never have happened, you know?
- Were any of you,
was there any people standing
up for you or anything?
- No, except for the girl
that came in after it,
that's pretty much it.
- Really?
- The rest of 'em were just
on the other side, filming it.
- Yeah, that's what I mean,
more people need to stand
up for bullying and like,
because it happens so much, and it's like,
it's one thing to get bullied
and stand up for yourself
but more people have to stand
in and actually do something,
because--
- Yeah, and stop it.
- Yeah, because people
just get bullied and--
- Yeah, well that's it,
you can't be a bystander
all your life, you know,
someone's got to step in and say,
stop, everyone has to stop.
("One Time" by Justin Bieber)
(people cheering)
- [Narrator] Right now, Justin Bieber
is one of the most popular
people on the planet.
Everywhere he goes, he's
surrounded by screaming fans.
But just a few years ago, it
was a very different story.
♫ And I just can't believe my first love
- Did you get bullied at school, Justin?
- I did, yeah.
It was actually something
that happened a lot for me.
You know, I was always, I
always played sports and stuff
and a lot of the times I would
be really good at something
and so everyone would wouldn't like me
because I was good at it
and they would make fun of me
and call me a showoff and stuff.
But I would just, I liked playing sports
and I was good at it.
♫ I mean to you
♫ Take care, my baby
- [Narrator] Like Casey,
Justin also found it hard to make friends.
- In sixth grade I just remember, I was,
I didn't have a lot of friends.
I had maybe one or two friends.
- I have one proper friend.
- One friend, I have two friends.
So I have one more but we're still
on the same level.
- Yeah, that's pretty good.
- We're on the same level, so yeah.
I have two friends, Ryan and Chaz
and they've been my friends
ever since I can remember
so I'm glad, you always
have to keep your core,
you know, friends and stuff but.
You got a lot of fans around the world.
- [Narrator] As a victim of bullies,
Justin felt inspired by Casey's story.
He was determined to track him down.
- He really wanted to make this happen
so he got in contact with
Woman's Day, phone rang,
it was Justin Bieber on
the other end of the line.
We went, wow, of course we've
going to make this happen
so we got in contact with you guys
and the rest is history.
- [Narrator] As it turned out,
one of Justin's crew had
a contact at Woman's Day.
The star himself asked
editor Fiona Connolly
to help find Casey.
- This is highly unusual.
You just don't see celebrities
giving this kind of treatment
to a regular kind of fan any day.
He's gone to extraordinary lengths.
- [Narrator] But Justin didn't
want to just meet Casey,
he wanted his help in spreading
the anti-bullying message.
- So I wanted to ask you
if you wanted to come on stage tonight
'cause I do this kind of,
you know, anti-bullying.
We do a lot of different stuff.
We do no texting and
driving during the show
so I wanted you to come
up and kind of just say hi
to everybody and just come on
stage, you want to do that?
- Yeah, I'll do that.
- Cool, all right.
So, it'll be around 9:30, you
think you can handle that?
- Yeah, I can handle that.
- Alright, cool.
We'll see you on stage.
- Yeah.
- Alright, pound it.
Alright guys.
♫ You want my love
- [Narrator] Justin made
sure Casey, his sister Tiana,
and dad Colin had front row seats.
And then, during a brief costume change,
the 16 year-old schoolboy
was taken backstage
for some last minute tips
from the teen sensation.
- You know what?
I want everybody to be quiet for a second
because I want to touch
on a serious subject.
I want to ask if anybody in
here has been bullied before.
(crowd cheering)
Okay, how many people in here
have seen people get bullied?
(crowd cheering)
All right, well, there was a story online.
A kid was getting bullied, right?
And at the end of the
video, he stood up for what,
you know, for himself,
because he was he was getting punched
and you know I want to bring him out here
because, you know, I think he can.
(crowd cheering)
What's up, man?
I think this kid is very
inspirational because.
Everybody give it up for this kid.
(crowd cheering)
I would tell you to body
slam Del but you know.
Anyways, but I just wanted to say
that he's very inspirational,
he shows other people to stand up
for what they believe in and what else?
What else?
You got to say it.
You got to say it really loud.
- Never say never!
(crowd cheering)
- [Narrator] Two kids,
once lonely, once bullied,
now adored by 13,000 screaming fans.
♫ I will never say never
♫ I will fight till wherever
- What was it like being
out there on the stage
with Justin Bieber?
- Oh, it was pretty good.
- In front of that?
- In front of that.
- [Interviewer] Did you
believe your brother was up
there with Justin Bieber?
- No, I couldn't at first, I'm just like,
no, this isn't happening.
This really isn't happening.
♫ 'Cause this is my destiny
♫ I will never say never
- Casey must've just felt
so special up on that stage.
He's only ever been up on stage once
and that was at the school
hall playing bass guitar.
So to have thousands of
screaming teenage girls
suddenly screaming for him,
I think that would've been such a special
experience for him.
- [Narrator] Fiona
Connolly from Woman's Day
says what happened on
that stage in Melbourne
will have an impact around the world.
- It sends a very important
message on bullying.
I mean, here's Justin Bieber,
superstar of the teen world
and he's saying, no, it's not all right.
- It was great, you know?
A really good thing
and it was good that Justin was prepared
to put out a message against bullying
and I thought that was fantastic.
- [Narrator] Long after
Justin had left the building,
fans were still caught up in Bieber Fever.
Casey, the boy they'd just seen onstage,
suddenly became the center of attention.
It was a moment he lapped up.
Mate, they are all screaming
for you, what's that like?
- It's amazing.
It's an unnatural feeling.
- [Narrator] And with screams
ringing in their ears,
even members of the band
wanted their photo taken
with Justin Bieber's new mate.
The kid who once suffered
at the hands of bullies,
now one of the boys.
- This is such an amazing story.
It's just such a beautiful,
feel good, inspiring story
and it really sheds a
great light on Justin
and Casey's enjoyed every minute of it.
♫ I never thought that I
could walk through fire
♫ I never thought that
I could take the burn
- How do you feel when all those
people come up and see you,
and all these girls here
want photos with you?
- Pretty good.
- Tiana, has Casey changed at all
since the last time we spoke to him?
- Yeah, he has.
His self-confidence has
picked up quite a bit.
- He stands a lot
straighter, mate, you know?
He looks a lot better to me.
- Nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you, too.
And it's nice to meet you dad.
Great, good kid.
♫ And never say never
- What surprised you the most
of actually being in person
and working with Justin Bieber,
from all the stuff, you
know, all the stereotypes
and everything you hear on
the media or whatever, maybe.
What surprised you the most?
- Doesn't even matter what anybody says.
He's the most talented,
gifted kid I've ever seen.
Like at everything.
At skateboard, he can beat
everyone at ping pong and pool.
He got like, when I got the Eye Hawk,
I actually showed him the Eye
Hawk, and he got right on it,
was doing, like, one
footed tricks and like,
he's just so talented and competitive
and wants to be good at everything.
He's also a really polite,
sweet person as well,
like, bringing my friends into the studio
and just other artists that I bring on
to the project to help
collaborate on the record.
He's on fire right now and
I think he's reinspired.
- During that experience that
you had with Justin Bieber,
is there a story that
you think will stand out?
That you'll be telling
in the future to, like,
your grandchildren and whatnot.
Like something that went down in studio
that was hilarious or so
weird or funky that went down?
- You know what?
On the real, I'm decent at skateboarding.
For not being like a skateboarder,
he almost beat me in a game of skate.
- [Host] Straight up.
- [Female Host] Almost being the keyword.
- Almost.
It's debatable, but he,
you have horse when you play
basketball, there's skate.
So you land a trick or you
do a trick, you land it.
If the other person doesn't land it,
you get a letter, S-K-A-T-E.
So we were playing skate
and he almost beat me.
And I was really surprised
that Justin Bieber almost
beat me at a game of skate.
That's what I'm saying,
he's good at everything.
He freestyles.
Like, sometimes we'll just make a beat
and then he'll get in the booth
and just start freestyling,
hilarious, like, comedian.
And we'll just be
sitting there in stitches
for like, 10 minutes,
not getting any work done
'cause he's just, like, telling jokes.
- I love that.
I love that guy.
That made me melt.
♫ Justin Bieber
♫ Damn, damn, JB, where the hell you been
♫ Yeah, I got a new necklace, diamonds
♫ Two big-faced Roleys, no I ain't lyin'
♫ Makin' momma so proud that she cryin'
♫ Yeah, you say I'm crazy,
guess that makes two
♫ But I never knew that
dreams really came true
♫ Started playin' drums
when I was only two
♫ Now we kick it in Japan, kung fu
♫ So I'm heading for
the gold, I'm sweating
♫ I swear Otis Redding will be oh so ready
♫ Already got aheady of the game
♫ I'm a Kenny, and we steady
gettin' many of me money
♫ Ridin' in a all-black Benz
♫ With the all-black rims and we lookin'
♫ At some 10s through our all-black lenses
Wait, I'm not done.
- [DJ] You're not done?
He ain't done, you all!
- Wait, wait.
♫ I thank Jesus at the awards
I'm never goin' to hell
♫ Call me Zack Morris,
I'm savin' you by the bell
♫ My girl says I'm perfect
♫ She just loves an
imperfect person perfectly
♫ Personally, I think
she is perfectly perfect
♫ Get it done abundantly
she wants to get up under me
♫ I swear that I got honey Ds
♫ 'Cause baby I'm a money tree
♫ So be my little honey
bee, my little bitty bunny
♫ I got honeys all up on me,
baby I just get it dunnie
♫ Possibly you're probably
thinkin' this type
♫ Of swag's impossible
♫ Illogically well probably
♫ But you just hear me lyrically
♫ Try to feel me spiritually,
get out your mind literally
♫ There's a bigger me inside
this little me, screamin' out
♫ I should make history,
I am like a mystery
♫ Hated by jealousy 'cause they envy me
♫ Run up on my enemies,
see if they remember me
♫ Soon as they remember me,
I'll wipe away they memory
♫ Can't you see the private
jets flyin' over you
♫ I ain't even notice,
but my focus on my photos
♫ Might be bogus, though they shouldn't be
♫ A photo shoot, it's funny
how you want to take my picture
♫ And it's like your first time
♫ Playing with the camera,
claimin' that it's not mine
♫ Just clam down, you don't got to hurry
♫ You don't, uh, don't be nervous
♫ You don't, you don't got to worry
♫ My fans are like my glasses, yeah
♫ Without 'em I'd be blurry
♫ Let me start off with
the old school flow
♫ Snapback, backpack, rat-a-tat, go
♫ Swagger out the knapsack,
who knew I could rap that
♫ Tell me where the cash at,
I'll tell you where to smash at
♫ Number one hits, I got number one flicks
♫ And the number one kicks,
and the number one chicks
♫ Fast like Gordon,
and my jams like Jordan
♫ And my Timbs like Hortons,
and my jets all a-boardin'
♫ And my wheels are like a fortune and
♫ It feels like extortion
♫ Is it for the fame or for the fortune
♫ Like this, mic this so I can recite this
♫ People in their basement
say I didn't even write this
♫ People say I'm white so
I couldn't do it like this
♫ Checks like Nike, let me
give you a good night kiss
♫ Well, I'm a little bit sick of it
♫ Listen to the bickering,
like picking on a little kid
♫ Like takin' all his licorice
♫ I hate it when they litterin'
♫ And I'd hate to be illiterate
♫ I literally am doin' these
♫ Riddlin', cheese like gouda
♫ And my soul like Buddha
♫ I'mma go right through ya
♫ And I'm so much cooler
♫ And I don't need Luda
to know that I'm the ruler
♫ And I'm so much cooler, you
should call me Ferris Bueller
- 2010 you were here.
That was five years ago.
I'm good at math, and you
had a drum off with Quest.
- I did, yep.
That was fun.
- Yeah, and it was,
yeah, well, yeah it was.
- I mean, I think you destroyed me but.
- No, it's okay, that doesn't matter,
this was five years ago.
But it's been five years.
(audience cheering)
- Are you saying a rematch?
- What's really good, Justin?
What's real, Justin?
(drum rolls)
- [Jimmy] Get him, man.
- [Quest] You go first?
- No, you go first.
(rhythmic drumming)
(audience cheering)
(fast rhythmic drumming)
(rhythmic drumming)
(audience cheering)
- That's what I'm talkin'
about right there, hey!
Do not miss Justin Bieber
performing his new single
with The Roots at the end of the show!
Salman Rushdie joins us after the break,
stick around, everybody!
Quest, come on back!
Come on back, you knocked him out!
(audience cheering and applauding)
(soft guitar music)
♫ You got a fast
♫ You, you got a, oh
♫ Fast car
♫ I got a ticket to anywhere
♫ Maybe we can make a deal
♫ Maybe together we can get somewhere
♫ Any place is better
♫ Starting from zero, got nothing to lose
♫ Maybe we'll make something
♫ Me, myself I got to nothing to lose
♫ See, my old man's got a problem
♫ He lives by the bottle,
that's the way it is
♫ I said body's too old for working
♫ Body's too young to look like this
♫ My momma went off and left him
♫ She wanted more from
life than he could give
♫ I said somebody's
got to take care of him
♫ So I quit school, that's what I did
♫ So remember we were driving
♫ Drivin' in your car
♫ Speeds so fast I felt like I was drunk
♫ City lights way out before
♫ And your arms is wrapped
right around my shoulder
♫ And I
♫ Had a feeling that I belonged
♫ Had a feeling I could be someone
♫ Be someone, be someone